Have a Muslim friends?
>> Of course. Of course. Um this this right
here, this topic here, the Quran
confirms the Bible is is my favorite
topic. It's my favorite thing that the
Quran talks about. Um what what's your
thoughts on it?
Take care, man. Be safe.
>> God bless you guys. Yeah, we believe in
Bible, too. Yeah. Yeah, and yeah, that's
that's where that's where we
have a common ground is that you guys
believe in the scriptures. After we're
done.
So, one of our faith
Yeah, it's one of the six articles you
got to believe in Allah, believe in his
books, his messengers, the angels, last
day. I think the other one is like uh
the decree of Allah. Yeah, so I think
you guys pretty much believe in all
those six things, right? Yes, um it's
it's just it's I think the where we
disconnect is is how we believe in them.
So, like I I was just talking to some
other Muslim brothers here today. They
were telling me that yes, they believe
in the the Bible, but it got corrupted.
It got tampered with. Do you share that
same belief?
I think it has been changed. Don't you
think? I I I don't think so. It hasn't
been changed? No. I I think that God did
a good job preserving his message. You
know, there there's of course when it
comes to ancient scripts, there's going
to be textual variances, but the message
or the meaning is still preserved. And
that's that's what I believe.
>> Because the thing is
the people who made the changes, like
you know, they might have a good
intention. I'm saying, "Okay, well,
let's change it for the time or
whatever." Like you know, all the
scholars in Christianity, let's say
I mean, we're not saying they were bad
people,
but
it has been changed from the original
text.
That's what we believe. The reason for
that is they say, you know,
sent that book for that time period. So,
he preserved it for that time. It did
not just have a revival.
So, any of the holy scriptures that were
Well, who didn't like some people didn't
like it, right? So, they they tried to
change it, right? So, same thing
happened So, we say it's just
continuation of the same message. I
mean, there are still parts of Bible
that are original. Like, you know, there
are people who study Bible, they they
know there is one subject where they
find out which one is the original text
and which one is the change. Yeah, so
this this is this is a an interesting
point to touch on. So, cuz obviously I
disagree that the scriptures has been
changed in that the the text is
corrupted, but you have that like
corrupted. But,
if there's a tempered with. I would say
that if you mean a change that there's
textual variances within manuscripts, of
course. I mean, the there's there's you
have that with every manuscript. You
even have that with like certain Quranic
manuscripts. My thing is that is that
the message within like those variances
don't change the context of what the
message is saying. Which is why a lot of
the, you know, textual critics though
they say like none of these variances
have any, uh, you know, meaning to or
they don't affect the meaning of the of
the text. Because, you know, the thing
is I'm not an expert, so I cannot really
say one way or the other. I'm very basic
person, right? So, I mean,
as a holy book, we believe in it. Yeah.
We believe it is from message from God.
Okay.
message from somebody else. Okay. Yeah,
yeah. Definitely believe in it. Same way
we believe in, uh, Torah, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. Or like any of
the scripts like the Ten Commandments.
Yeah, that's in the Torah.
And then, you know, you have all those
things. So, you believe in all those
things. That's good. So, so then so
okay, so this is where we the the
But, the important part is for me then.
So,
to believe in the scriptures, obviously
you got to believe in what they say. So,
and this is where the divide comes is
where Okay, when I compare the Quran
what it says and what the what the Bible
says, obviously there are key things
that they differ on. Like,
one important thing is that Allah is
completely by himself, he has no
partners, he doesn't beget nor is he
begotten, right?
>> Yeah. In the Bible, in the Gospel, the
Injil teaches that Jesus is the son of
God who came from who came down from
heaven and to believe in him for eternal
life. So, the Quran says if you say
Allah has a son, you've committed
blasphemy. If you Jesus says you got to
believe he's the son of God or else
>> Because you know, the thing is it's just
like
we see it as like a version, you know?
Let's say you know you have a version of
a book or a standard.
>> Mhm.
So, you know, you have 2.0 and then 3.0.
So, whatever the latest standard is
normally you follow, Right. Okay.
Because we see this continuation of the
same message. Like Quran is not
something new, it's just continuation of
the same message. Mhm. Wou- wou- would
you say then that if if the Gospels
teaching, cuz this this is where it's
like it's the opposite message. Like,
okay. In Muhammad's time, this is a one
of my favorite verses, it's important to
me, it's chapter 5 Surah Al-Ma'idah,
I have 47. It says,
>> Yeah. "Let the people of the Gospel
judge by what Allah has revealed in it."
Right? So, in Muhammad's time, even
while the Quran is there, the Quran
tells the people of the Christians to
judge by the Gospel, right? He says use
the Gospel. So, if I judge by the
Gospel, then I I'm
I have to judge that the Quran is
actually not a true revelation because
it's saying the opposite thing about
Jesus, you know? And that's where the
conundrum is. Because you know, that's
that's because you know, I'm not like no
expert. So, that's what I'm saying. So,
basically
for us it's just like it's the new
version of Bible, you could say. Okay.
Quran. Because the Bible is from God,
right? Yeah. Yeah.
Revealed by God.
>> Yeah. Same way the Quran is revealed by
God. It's not like Prophet Muhammad did
not even know how to read or write.
Right. Right. Right. Right? Mhm. So,
whatever is So, it's just it's that's
why there is a lot of
great respect even to Christians and
Jews because I consider people of the
book.
>> Yeah, people of the book, that's right.
>> Because
that's they were the given the previous
book, right? Yeah. So that's why So we
have great respect for them. I mean, we
I understand that not everybody is going
to say, "Okay, you know, Quran is the
new book of God. Let's follow him." Not
everybody is going to do that. So since
for you Bible is
final
like the book of God you will be so
glad. It's not for me to judge you. You
know what I'm saying? Yeah. Or to judge
the Jews, "Hey, hey, why you haven't
converted?" I mean, of course, we invite
them. Yeah.
>> But it's not for us to judge anybody.
Yeah, yeah. So so on touching on that
point, like so the Quran is very like
it does appeal to the Jews and
Christians saying, "Hey, you should
believe also in Muhammad as a prophet."
And one of the reasons, well, really the
main reason is because he confirms what
you have. He's He's in line. He's a
continuation of what you have, right? So
that's how they're supposed to recognize
him as a messenger of God. Yeah. Now, so
if I'm doing it if I'm taking that
seriously, I'm looking at this
genuinely. I'm like, "Okay, you know
what? Let me look at Muhammad and let me
see if he is indeed in line with what I
have, right?" And so when I do that, I
honestly if I have to I have to be
honest with myself, I don't see that
he's in line because he says that Jesus
wasn't crucified. He says Jesus is not
the son of God.
>> the decision of opinion I think even
within some
from what I understand within even
within some Christians.
>> Oh, no. All All Christians believe Jesus
is the son of God and was crucified.
>> The main thing is is
the message of the text doesn't really
change all because of it. We also still
believe that he's going to come back
before the day of judgment. But Allah
says if we believe that Jesus is the son
of God that he curses those. Because you
know, if you call him son of God in a
respectful way, let's say somebody say,
"Hey, son, come here." Mhm. He's not my
son, but I'm calling him son in a
from respectful way.
That's we have no issue. But it. if you
say that you know, he's like a begotten
son of God, that's different, right?
Yeah. Let me get your thoughts on this.
So so can I hear what you're saying,
right?
It's calling someone like a term of
endearment, right? Not a literal son,
but like metaphorically, right? So
I I thought of this, too. And so the
Quran talks about different senses in
which people say that Allah has a has a
son, whether it's metaphorical or
whether it's begotten, stuff like that.
He rejects all of that. Now here here's
a verse where Allah like makes it clear
the type of relationship we can have in
Surah Maryam. Um chapter 19, verse verse
93. If you read the context, it's about
him having a son. They say Allah has a
son. He says, "No, he doesn't, right?"
Now verse 93, he caps it off. He says,
"There's none in the heavens or the
earth that can come to the most
beneficent except as a servant, as a
slave, right?" So he even rejects any
metaphorical way that you can come to
Allah as a child of his. Yeah, yeah,
that. Because God itself, he is what?
Like we don't associate anyone with him.
So
What were What are you going to say?
No no, this is a great conversation,
man. It was so nice to meet you. Avery.
Avery.
>> Yes, sir. A V E R Y.
>> Yes, sir.
>> I'm Suleiman. Suleiman. Nice to meet
you, Suleiman. I have a friend named
Suleiman. Okay, nice to meet you,
Suleiman. All right, nice to meet you.
God bless you. Have a good rest of your
day, okay?
Yeah, awesome conversation. Great
conversation. Guy was really going to
consider things and listen and think.
And that's what we're here to do, man.
We're here to you know, just have these
dialogues. You know, get them to think
about these things a little different,
plant seeds, you know? He's older
gentleman, so hopefully he thinks about
these things and takes it a little
seriously.
Um because the Quran is clear, you know,
if you say that Allah has a son, Jesus
is his son, you're cursed. The gospel is
clear that unless you believe in the
name of the son of God, Jesus Christ,
you'll perish and you're condemned
already. So, these two messages cannot
coexist. They can't exist at the same
time.
You know, so believe and repent and
believe in the gospel.
Is God